welcome to the heavy spoilers show
you're now locked into the channel where
we break down all of the latest movies
TV shows games and comic books
I'm your host definition and it's time
to save the world with the help of the
planets newest superhero Dione
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the ending of raising Dione and
this show's big twist there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the Netflix series
yet and don't want anything ruined then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our ending explain
breakdown of racing Dion razing Dion
follows Nicole Warner played by Alicia
Wainwright as she raises her
super-powered son Dion in the absence of
his father mark played by Michael B
Jordan Dion is a modern marvel pun
intended and possesses a whole host of
superpowers including the ability to
teleport move things with his mind turn
invisible and heal creatures whilst
initially this skill set seems like it
could be a dream come true for the
character we quickly learn that being a
superhero isn't easy the series deals
with all the trials and tribulations
that would come from having a son with
special abilities and it's a pretty
unique aesthetic that though heavily
explored and bright Byrne develops here
far beyond its cinematic counterpart
from the off the main focus is Nicole's
worry that a son has been tasked with a
huge responsibility and just as much as
his actions matter so do hers she has
the potential to raise the world's
greatest hero or its biggest threat and
this is something that she struggles
with throughout guiding him down the
right path whilst outside forces tried
to corrupt him there's a real sense of
this being steeped in comic books even
down to the episodes being called issues
with corresponding season and episode
numbers instead of simply episode 1 or
whatever they all have comic-book
related names that range from things
like why so vomity today's of marks
Future past and fortress of solitude
this tone very much carries throughout
the show whether being the usual
superhero origin story archetypes
including the death of a parent and so
on however at its heart is the fact that
anyone and no matter their age race or
background
can become someone important start the
season begins with Dion really
struggling to fit in at school and its
mother Nicole has to deal with life as a
single parent overwhelmed by her son's
abilities we learned early on that mark
passed away after saving a woman from
drowning but in doing so sacrificed
himself there's a real back and forth
throughout the season as to his true
fate and the real events that led to his
death and his absence becomes a big
driving force even though the truth
about his passing remains a mystery for
the opening episodes it's really
heartbreaking watching both Nicole and
Dion dealing with the fact that he is
out of their lives
however he definitely isn't a bad force
and the fact that his death was due to
heroic circumstances influences Dion in
many positive ways
when Dion's abilities emerge he has
difficulty controlling them and on a
trip to his lakeside home he pretty much
wrecks the ecosystem there and almost
kills himself and his mother he also
lashes out at a boy at school for
stealing his father's watch and it
becomes clear that his emotions often
get the better of him I guess with great
power comes great responsibility and
early on this draws the eyes of ghosts
including his father who warned the pair
to get away they remain put though at
the Lakeside and after a woman
disappears in the area Nicole suspects
that there may be other forces at work
in addition to this she discovers that
before marks death he was visiting the
woman that he saved initially she
believed that they were strangers but
this revealed paints a different picture
especially as it's shown that she went
off the map the day that mark died upon
returning home Nicole is forced into
basically a juggling act of getting a
job looking after his son and keeping
her home tidy and it's rare that we get
a depiction of life as a single mother
in a superhero centric story but raising
Dion does an excellent job of giving
this perspective some life and actually
making it engaging nicole says it best
when she refers to it like having a
toddler roll over again but he can crash
cause with his mind this nails the call
of racing Dion and makes it easy to
connect with all of the performances
here are grounded believable and easy to
connect with and even characters that I
thought I wouldn't find common ground
with portrayed their lives in ways that
were easy to relate to the human side of
raising Dion is definitely its strong
point and this elevates the show
massively early on it also drives the
plot which eventually sees Nicole catch
up with a woman
mark was in contact with and she learns
that Mark had powers too which explains
how Dion inherited them the woman named
Charlotte took divulges that everyone
who went to see the Northern Lights in
Iceland during a meteor shower received
powers this is known as the Aurora event
and it granted all of the onlookers with
superhuman abilities mark was present at
this and like the rest of the group
received a specific super-powered
skillset that they had to hide from
society she also explains that there is
a human storm that killed mark and
absorbed him and this sets up the
villain of the piece known as the
crooked man the crooked man is a being
of pure energy that constantly hunts the
super-powered citizens and aware that he
is coming Sharla agrees to Train Dion
and this is very much the point in which
he finally begins to gain control of his
powers Pat Nicole's friend works at the
same company that Mark used to and we
discovered that they have several
citizens that receive powers under
surveillance and from here on Nicole and
Pat build a database of contacts that
they can go to to discover more
information this corporation seemingly
has ties to the crooked man and has been
keeping tabs on all those presence at
the Aurora event which allows Charlotte
to track them down
Pat quickly becomes a father figure to
Dion and in some ways he guides and
raises him through the values and
beliefs that he inherited from comic
books it really takes the story from
quite a simple one about family to one
that is about the ins and outs of
pressures that come from dealing with
extraordinary gifts the show ramps up
episode by episode going from a
simplistic tale to one full of corporate
espionage privacy invasions and
supervillains that far out match the
majority of the characters in the show
Raising Dion really got its hooks into
me and at just nine episodes I found
myself binging through the entire piece
and less than a day desperate to find
out how it will conclude and which
characters would make it to the end
Charlotte discovers a boy named Braden
that inherited powers from his father
who was also killed by the crooked man
similar to mark
unlike Dion no Braden takes the death of
his father really badly and his auntie
who not takes care of him and forces the
belief that his father possessed demonic
powers that he sets him off down a dark
path and the finale of the show begins
to paint him out as a nemesis that Dion
could face should a second season come
about
as the season progresses Pat becomes
attached to Dianna in Nicole but the
latter rebuffed his advances which anger
him and he forms the opinion that he is
being used Pat was also at the event
that Mach gained his powers at and now
he denied receiving any due to being in
an observation deck we learn in the
final few episodes that this is in fact
a lie and that Pat is the crooked man he
has been manipulating Dion to follow in
his footsteps and see the world his way
and has secretly coveted his healing
powers as well as a relationship with
Nicole after the constant rejection from
her Pat finally uses their and we
learned that his powers come with a
curse that constantly makes him sicker
and sicker
thus he must consume are the powered
people in order to stay alive which
explains his motives in the show he has
had his eyes set on Dion because he
wants him to become strong enough to
heal him even though it could probably
kill the boy in the end this leads to a
showdown between Dion and Nicole and Pat
who managed to seemingly defeat the
crooked man due to the appearance of
Mark who materializes in the final
battle to help save his son after the
fight in which the crooked man is
defeated mark manages to hold his son
and even kiss his wife explaining that
energy never really dies as Einstein
discovered this is true of all things
and thus it allows mark to come back and
see them one final time however he also
comes with a warning and that due to the
previous statement the crooked man will
still be out there
Dion promises to find a way to bring
mark back and going forward I believe
that this will be a big focus of the
second season as well as the cliffhanger
that comes at the end this centers
around Brayden who he jointed his home
to discover his aunt is dead and that
mark is now using him as a vessel
tapping into the boys dark side in order
to control him and manipulate him much
in the same way that he tried to do with
Dion throughout the show whilst Braden
is possessed I do think that he will
have some say in the matter
and as mentioned earlier he will likely
take on an ark that marries Dion just
for bad instead of good with Pat being
his only guiding force and no Nicole to
balance it out he will likely turn to
the dark side and I think this is all
ramping up to a showdown between Braden
and Dion for season two now Braden does
still have hope
and he's an age where there is time to
change so I can imagine that during the
conflict he may reject Pat
with the help of Dion finally destroy
the crooked man either way I'm really
excited for a second season and I can't
wait to see what happens in it but what
did I think of raising Dion overall well
well the thing that the CGI felt that at
some points and there were some arcs
that could have been left on the cutting
room floor overall this is a fun
superhero origin story that uses its
heart and message to elevate above the
trappings of slightly lackluster effects
this is definitely raising Dion's strong
point and it's a unique take on the
superhero story in a world that's full
of them raising Dion is a really good
ride and I'm annoyed at myself for
taking so long to get round to it as
overall I think everyone will find
something to enjoy here and that's why
it gets an 8 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts and razing Dion and what you
hope to see in the second season comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out my
breakdown of this week's other big
Netflix release Eli which would be
linked at the end I go over the entire
film and it's ending so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to come chat to me
after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which you'll be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 boxing blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming and Ragnarok and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on raising Deon in the comments
section below
the one it's gonna be chosen the 15th of
November and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprised it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you